marc adopté écrit la porte
un prof n'a pas besoin d'être aimée mais
d'être compris la dame j'équipe à de
graves difficultés pédagogiques ne sait
pas faire une escale en scène le lycée
est un sanctuaire dédié à l'étude
le respect et le vivre ensemble et vont
pas ton corps soit tendu par la main
sinon plus de lui une petite chose à mon
cri
je ne me souviens de rien sinon une
chaleur rue poussantes caisse
c'est la première agence numérique en 30
ans de carrière pourquoi elle et pas
mort il y à quelques initiatives
pédagogiques intéressante et un peu
gadget aussi
il s'est passé quelque chose
qui aurait dit que c'est petit bout de
femme insignifiant aurait la place qu'il
a aujourd'hui dans le lycée
[Musique]
t'es quoi l'essentiel savoir comment
être heureux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]